who I mean obviously Lady Gaga uh yeah
but see Gaga was on Khan live at the
time I had two labels check you out I
had con live which was the pop label and
then I had convict music which was the
urban label there's always speculation
are you still getting money off of Lady
Gaga no no not no more not no more how
many albums in was it before the bag
stopped I had it for four albums Christ
you had it for four albums so after the
four albums the deal is over but then
how do does she have four albums nah she
never got to fall
so you eventually were like hey look
well at that time it was a lot of moving
parts
and I kind of seen where the future was
going because of how the parts were
moving and that's when I made a deal
for
my portion and steak of her and I bought
out I sold out oh so you sold your
portion of whatever she doesn't matter
right before the dip oh that's smart do
you think that that's why artists are
currently selling their catalog right
now like they're publishing because they
feel like it's a depreciating asset
maybe
um no I think a lot of them are are
selling for because they don't know they
don't I don't think they know the value
of what that is they're selling yeah
because I saw like future sell like a
ridiculous amount of titles for like 75
million a lot of people were like yo he
probably should have got more well
actually
yeah that many like future I think he
could have got definitely more for for
the amount of titles he sold out yeah
um but sometimes they look at it
differently like when you're coming from
the street you're looking at how you can
flip the 75 million right so maybe he
has some other [ __ ] that line up future
ain't stupid like of course smart guy
and I'm sure he's like okay cool
I can go and pull this away because just
people don't really even know that that
interest just on that 75 million he can
live forever not have a work work ever
again yeah if you manage your money
properly put that Park that money in
certain you know Ventures you'll never
have that money pays for your lifestyle
forever literally
so now everything you make on this side
is bonus strip club money that's
beautiful you know what was was it a
comparable bag for your Lady Gaga buy
out it was enough to for me to retire
I hadn't made a record since until now
that's crazy so would you say that like
obviously being a part of Lady Gaga's
career being able to capitalize off that
you took a chance on her early Just
Dance Poker Face all that [ __ ] is it was
worth it it was worth every painting
she's another one that I treat like
T-Pain I'm always and forever be there
for how was your uh how was your current
relationship with her oh same same yeah
yeah what was it about her because I
feel like when she first came into the
game
I don't think we really understood how
talented she was because she wasn't
necessarily diving into the type of
records that fully show us her her
potential yeah her range right right so
what was it about what you saw in her
early on that like you know you were
like oh yeah nah yeah well the thing is
I had already recognized all of that and
I was like man if she get the chance to
be able to express herself as a real
artist and not be pushed left or right
for a label telling her what she can and
cannot do she's gonna be out of here wow
because she's she's the kind of person
that creates like movements and I saw
that as we was promoting her and how she
was creating that monster movement in
itself I was like oh this is big all we
gotta do now just let her do her yeah I
think that's what happened with the
second album right yeah first album was
like kind of like the first album was
push more between me and red one giving
her the sound that we felt can break her
through and it worked and it worked and
then the second album was really more
her taking over saying okay thank you
guys for the you know training wheels
now I'm gonna go just like was bad
romance on the second album I was on the
first oh it was on the first oh well
[ __ ] that's one of my favorite songs
yeah shout out to Lady Gaga yeah she's a
legend man that's a joke man she's a
legend without a doubt